a defeat you're obsessed with the idea
that computers should constantly raise
the bar on what them can get done at the
mundane so that our users your employees
have more and more time to focus and
truly creative work and today three of
our apps are an over a billion
smartphones we have over three million
paying businesses that use the GP here
are three examples of recent early
adopter programs that we've done each of
these apps is something that was built
for enterprises only the gem board app
makers Google's cloud search every one
of these is an enterprise only product
Google Drive today has over 800 million
monthly active users I'll be making five
announcements now first team drive goes
into general availability today and it
lets Kings
easily share content in their drive and
manage the sharing in pleased to
announce general availability for Google
vault for drive content say I see a few
people reset about that as well thank
you that's all very well for content in
the cloud but most of my contents it's
an on-premise file servers what do I do
about that I'm ecstatic to announce that
we are acquiring vancouver-based app
bridge a bridge is a company that builds
connectors from on-premise file servers
to cycle that content up into Google
Drive Google's machine learning magic
will build a predictive model for who
you are your activity and serve up that
file before you even ask for it this we
call the quick access we rebuilt Google
Hangouts with a focus on making teams
productive completely rebuilt to be an
intelligent messaging app for teams but
in the new hangouts chat
we've added rooms rooms are a central
place for team and project discussion so
what you're seeing here is the new
hangouts meet our enterprise solution
for video meetings the jam board knows
that there's a meeting going on and
automatically presents a prompt and with
one click TJ can join the meeting and
present the jam board to the meeting we
decided that it was time for Gmail the
add-on capability because people were
wasting simply too much time going from
the primary work surface which could be
Gmail digressing over to a distraction
and then but it's time to come back 20
minutes are gone now remember he's still
in Gmail he's never left the application
and he isn't able to fill out the
invoice entirely in there
boom he sends the invoice and he's done
it was that easy we've seen many
positive impacts of our of our move to G
suite but one in particular like the
highlight is when we ask question around
productivity and productivity
improvement the average the estimated
average productivity enhancement and
gain per week was nearly 9 hours it's at
a low showcase the Gmail add-ons and
we've been working with a bunch of other
partners to build out exciting new I
don't
[Music]